well as you continue to follow the
corona virus saga that is out there the
panic and hysteria continues to escalate
people who are normally level-headed are
becoming mean angry and out of control
and they're doing damage to themselves
and to others around them because of
their ignorance and their hysteria and
it's really a sad thing that it's
happening
my friend art Laffer says no one makes
good decisions when they're panicked or
when they're drunk and when you are
panicked you don't make good decisions
calm down you're gonna be okay calm down
you're gonna be okay you really are I I
know you're scared no no I know some of
you are completely freaked out to the
point that the your your voice tone is
changing the octaves are shifting in
your throat because of the tightness in
it if you catch yourself doing that
you're just a beagle chasing a rabbit at
this point I mean calm down calm down
you're gonna be okay some of you lost
your jobs I understand we do a lot of
business with Marriott all of their all
of their various brands all the way from
the Ritz down to whatever the other
brands are and through a whole bunch of
their properties and wonderful people we
enjoy working with them and they laid
off 10,000 people today oh this week
10,000 Wow now is Marriott gonna close
down ritz-carlton gonna close down no
not permanently no they're most of those
folks them if they want their jobs back
we'll be able to go back there but it's
pretty disturbing for those people that
just went home not getting a paycheck
and that's just one example of many out
there
because of this demand that everyone
close by people on their way to work
yeah it's uh it's out of control
it's out of control and you know public
health issues are real the virus is real
the good news is is that way less than
3,500 4000 cases in the US and less than
a hundred deaths in the u.s. and of
course we all know that that's
substantially less than the flu
substantially less than car wrecks but
none of you quit driving cars you're
still driving cars all over the place
calm down the number of my friends that
I thought had a brain that have called
me in the past 24 hours
screeching about getting out of the
stock market because it's going to
completely collapse let me explain
something to you
if the Fortune 500 the 500 largest
companies in America all become worth
zero you understand that the United
States of America has come to an end
so when you have the presupposition in
your decision-making
you've panicked to the point or you've
been drinking to the point that you
think that the stock market is going to
become worth zero the set of assumptions
you've used to do that mean that you
have decided that the United States of
America is going to come to an end that
the entire economy has collapsed and
really a foreign power will come in at
that point that's the decision you're
making now guys that's asinine and some
of you were acting exactly the same way
after nine-one-one and some of you were
acting exactly the same way after 2008
when are you going to learn that we're
more resilient than that and the
capitalism in this economy is way more
resilient than that it's off 5% today 5%
that's
we're going to die oh my god calm down
calm down
no you can argue about how long it's
going to take it to go back to where it
was it's under 20,000 probably today it
was at 30 how long is it gonna take it
to get back you can argue about how it
takes it to get back but if you make the
argument based on the fact that the
possibility of your of your mutual funds
becoming worth zero and it never returns
ever coming back then you're making the
argument that the United States of
America our economy has collapsed
completely not taking a hit not taking a
bow not taking a step back has
completely gone that's asinine
that's absurd you need to breathe count
to ten now I think it'll be back inside
of twelve months there's a lot of
historical data to indicate that after 9
1 1 the market douve after 9 1 1 and it
was on headlines everywhere based on the
attack on the towers based on the
terrorism based on the crazy people
taking over planes based on all of that
the market douve by the way those bricks
were showered literally on the Wall
Street or the stock exchange are yes
they felt the literal bricks hitting
there the market douve you know how long
it took it to come by ways headlines in
every newspaper every newscast you know
how long it took it to come completely
back from that dive anybody wanna take a
guess 57 days it was back before
Christmas did you see a single headline
with that back then that the market was
so resilient that it completely
recovered the 9-1-1 losses in 57 days
you cannot find an article written
anywhere but all you gotta do is pull up
your Dow Jones Industrial Average are
your S&P 500 charts and you can look at
it and see it but not a single headline
said that
and the people who lost money when the
market went down and panicked went away
are still going around 20 years later
telling everyone how they lost all their
money after 9 1 1 which they didn't by
the way they lost some of their money
because they're so stupid they sold at
the very bottom calm down how long do
you take to come back after 2008 year
year and a half I don't remember the
exact number of days on that one I was
gonna take it to come back after this
less than a year financially it's not as
big as Oh 8 that's my prediction and
that's worth what you pay for it
economists and weather forecasters are
the only people that can be wrong all
the time and still keep their jobs so
I'm probably wrong might be quicker
might be longer but is it going to take
10 years for the United States to
recover from this absolutely not
that's Asuna calm down you're all right